foreign
this is Professor mdos science and today
we will discuss the ground state of the
hydrogen atom in another one of our
videos on rigorous quantum mechanics the
hydrogen atom is an iconic system in
physics for example it is the simplest
of all elements and also the most
abundant element in the universe
the hydrogen atom is also one of the
very very few systems for which we can
actually solve analytically the
associated quantum mechanical equations
details of the mathematical derivation
of the hydrogen atom energy eigenvalues
and eigenvectors in one of our videos
that is linked in the description what
we will do today is to explore some of
the Key properties of the ground state
of the hydrogen atom which are used as a
benchmark for all other systems
specifically we will discuss the
ionization energy which is the energy
required to dissociate the proton and
the electron when the hydrogen atom is
in the ground state and we will also
discuss the typical size of the hydrogen
atom which is given by the so-called
bore radius so let's go
the hydrogen atom is made of two
particles a proton and an electron
we can draw this by considering a
coordinate system and describing the
proton with the corresponding position
operator like this and the electron with
the corresponding Precision operator
like this
now of course the proton and electron
live in a 3D space but for Simplicity
I'm just including two dimensions in
this schematic
we know from the introductory video on
hydrogen that the relevant physics of
the system is encoded by the relative
motion of the proton and the electron
which is captured by this relative
position vector
based on this we describe the hydrogen
atom with a one particle relative
hamiltonian h
the hamiltonian has a kinetic energy
term and a potential energy term
in the position representation we can
rewrite it with the usual kinetic energy
term and the potential energy term which
has the form of a central potential
for a full derivation of this relative
hamiltonian I refer you to the
introductory video on the hydrogen atom
but just to ask a quick reminder mu here
is the reduced mass of the system and is
related to the masses of the proton and
electron by this equation
P here is the relative momentum given by
this expression in terms of the
individual momentum of the proton and
electron and R here is the relative
position which as we show in the diagram
is given by the distance between the
proton and the electron
now this relative hamiltonian is the key
to understanding the hydrogen atom using
quantum mechanics
specifically we can write the eigenvalue
equation of the hamiltonian like this
where as usual these are the eigenvalues
and these are the eigenfunctions
the eigenvalues are labeled by a quantum
number n here which can only take
positive integer values
the eigenfunctions are also labeled by n
and two additional quantum numbers L
here and ml here which are associated
with orbital angular momentum
we have solved this eigenvalue equation
to determine all bound states of the
hydrogen atom in a series of more
mathematical videos that are linked in
the description
and what we want to do today is to focus
on the ground state energy and wave
function which will allow us to expand
our conceptual understanding of the
hydrogen atom
so let's go straight to the ground state
energy
remember that we can write the energy
eigenvalues of the hydrogen atom as
equal to minus V ionization energy Over
N squared and remember that the
ionization energy is given by this
expression in terms of the reduced mass
and of fundamental physical constants
from this General expression we can
write the ground state energy E1 as
equal to the negative of the ionization
energy and explicitly we get this
let's put some numbers into this
expression and let's start with the
reduced Mass mu which we can write using
this expression in terms of the electron
and proton masses
in SI units the proton mass is equal to
1.673 times 10 to the minus 27 kilograms
and the electron mass is equal to
9.109 times 10 to the minus 31 kilograms
if we pluck these numbers into the
expression for the reduced Mass we find
a value of
9.104 times 10 to the minus 31 kilograms
now if we compare the reduced Mass here
with the electron Mass here we see that
they are very close to each other
and that is because the proton mass is
several orders of magnitude larger than
the electron mass and as we discussed in
the introductory video on the hydrogen
atom the relative motion of the proton
and electron in hydrogen is to a very
good approximation describing the motion
of an electron around a stationary
proton
to evaluate the ground state energy we
also need the numerical values of the
three fundamental physical constants
the fundamental charge e is equal to
1.602 times 10 to the minus 19 coulomb
the permittivity of free space is equal
to
8.854 times 10 to the minus 12 meters to
the power of minus 3 kilogram to the
power of minus one second to the power
of 4 and and pair squared
and the reduced Planck constant is equal
to
1.055 times 10 to the minus 34 Joule
second
plugging these numerical values into the
expression for the ground state energy
of hydrogen which is equal to minus the
ionization energy we get minus
2.176 times 10 to the minus 18 joules
when we work with atomic systems the SI
unit of energy the Joule is actually not
a very useful unit because we end up
with very small values like the one that
we just got
instead we typically use the electron
volt as the unit of energy which is
abbreviated as EV
one electron volt is defined as the
kinetic energy gained by an electron in
vacuum starting from wrist and
accelerating through a potential
difference of one volt
with this definition one electron volt
is equal to 1.602 times 10 to the minus
19 joules and using this relation we can
convert the gram State energy of
hydrogen to electron volts obtaining a
value of minus 13.6 electron volts
right so what does that number tell us
remember from the earlier videos on
hydrogen that the Zero Energy
corresponds to a proton and electron
that are infinitely apart in this
context negative energies correspond to
bound States and the ground state energy
being negative means that the ground
state of the electron proton system is
that of a bound hydrogen atom
the precisely numerical value is telling
us that if we have a hydrogen atom in
its ground state then we need to provide
an energy of 13.6 electron volts to
unbind the electron from the proton
the minimum energy required to remove an
electron from a neutral atom in its
ground state is generally called the
ionization energy and this explains the
name that we have given to EI which we
initially introduced as a mathematical
shorthand
let's now move to the ground state wave
function
remember that we can write a general
eigenfunction of the hydrogen atom as
equal to a radial part multiplying an
angular part
the eigenfunctions are labeled by three
quantum numbers n here which we've seen
is associated with the different energy
eigenvalues
L which is a quantum number associated
with the total angular momentum of the
system
and ml here which is the quantum number
associated with the zit component of
angular momentum
the angular part of the eigenfunctions
is given by spherical harmonics while
the radial part takes a rather complex
mathematical form that we explore in
some of the other videos on hydrogen
so the ground state corresponds to n
equals 1 L equals zero and ml equals
zero
with these quantum numbers the radial
part of the eigenfunction which is r 1 0
is given by this prefactor times an
exponential
the angular part y 0 0 is given by a
constant and bringing these together we
can write at the full ground state wave
function PSI one zero zero as equal to
this prefactor times the exponential
function and again a reminder that we
derive all of these results in the
linked companion videos so check them
out if you want to know where the
Expressions come from
these diagrams are a depiction of the
ground state to wave function of the
hydrogen atom
the figure on the left shows the radial
part of the ground state wave function
it has a maximum at the origin and then
decays exponentially away from it
the figure on the right shows the
angular part which is the y 0 0
spherical harmonic and it is a constant
if you need to remind yourself of how to
draw spherical harmonics then check out
the corresponding video that we have
Linked In the description
but just briefly spherical harmonics
depend on the angular variables Theta
and Phi so we can plot them on the unit
sphere and we use a red white blue color
gradient scale with red corresponding to
positive white is zero and blue is
negative
and in this case we get a uniform red
sphere because the y00 spherical
harmonic is a positive constant
so overall the ground state wave
function or the hydrogen atom takes its
maximum value at the origin of the
potential and then decays away from the
origin in an isotropic manner
next we're going to explore in some more
detail what we can learn from this
ground state wave function and in
particular we're going to focus on the
proton electron distance
the first question that we ask is what
is the probability of finding the
electron at a given position Vector R
measured from the proton
and before we answer this question we
need a clarification as R is a
continuous variable then a precise value
of R is basically meaningless
what we should really ask is what is the
probability of finding the electron
around R within the volume element Dr
we're going to call this probability
capital P of R Dr and it is equal to the
absolute value of the ground state wave
function squared times a volume element
centered at r
this should all be very familiar we're
simply using the standard interpretation
of the absolute value squared of a wave
function as providing the probability
density of the position of a particle
and then multiplying by the volume
element to obtain the probability
spelling out the ground state wave
function we can rewrite this probability
in terms of the radial part and the
angular part and the volume element
we can also insert the expression that
we have for the wave function at the top
here and we end up with this expression
finally we can spell out the volume
element in terms of the spherical
coordinates are Theta and Phi
and rewrite the probability like this
now you'll probably agree with me that
this expression is not particularly
enlightening
we could put some values in for the
position R of the electron with respect
to the proton here and then evaluate the
actual probability but we wouldn't learn
that much
one of the reasons for this is that the
ground state wave function of the
hydrogen atom is isotropic which means
that it is the same in any direction
mathematically this is reflected by the
fact that there is no explicit angular
dependence on the wave function up here
and this suggests that to make progress
it will be more useful to focus on the
radial coordinate only and this is what
we will do next
so the next question we ask is what is
the probability of finding the electron
at a given distance R from the nucleus
and note that here we're talking about
the scalar distance R from the nucleus
and not the vector position r that we
were discussing in the previous slide
before we answer this question we need
the same clarification that we had in
the previous slide as the scalar
distance R is a continuous variable what
we should really ask is what is the
probability of finding the electron at a
distance in the interval R and R plus Dr
from the nucleus
we're going to call this probability
lowercase p of R times Dr
and it is equal to the absolute value
squared of the radio function times the
infinitesimal radial element
and when we only consider the distance
from the origin we need to average over
all possible angular directions so we
need to integrate over the angular parts
let's first focus on the angular
integrals
we can use the fact that y 0 0 is equal
to the constant 1 over square root of 4
pi to take its Square 1 over 4 Pi
outside followed by the integrals over
the angular coordinates
these integrals give the solid angle of
the full 3d space which is 4 pi and we
end up with one
inserting this results inside the
probability of finding the electron at a
distance R from the proton we get the
absolute value squared of the radial
function times r squared Dr
so what does all of this mean
the probability of finding the electron
at a distance R from the proton P of R
times Dr is equal to this expression
in this expression pfr is what we call
the probability density of finding the
electron at a distance R from the proton
and it is given by the square of the
radial function times r squared we can
find an explicit expression for it by
plugging in the value of the radial
function for the ground state we have at
the very top here and we get this
prefaxer times r squared times this
exponential
this expression gives the probability
density associated with finding the
electron at a distance R from the proton
irrespective of the direction and this
probability density is what we will use
next to learn more about the ground
state of the hydrogen atom
the diagram on the left shows the
probability density that we've just
derived for finding the electron at a
distance R from the proton
as a reminder in the diagram on the
right I'm showing again the radial part
of the ground state wave function which
has a maximum at the origin and decays
away from it
now at First Sight these two plots may
look inconsistent
how is it possible that given the shape
of the wave function the probability of
finding the electron at a distance R
from a proton has the shape shown on the
left with a clear maximum some distance
away from the origin
to properly understand this Behavior we
need to remember that we really have a
3D system and apart from the radial
Direction shown in these plots we also
have angular directions
this function p on the left shows the
probability of finding the electron at a
distance R from the proton irrespective
of the direction in which we look
Fab means that when we consider an
electron at a distance R from the proton
this electron could be at any point on a
sphere of radius R centered on the
proton
as we move farther away from the origin
the surface of this sphere grows and
therefore the number of positions in
which the electron can be also grows
mathematically the growth of the
spherical area as we move away from the
origin is captured by this r squared
term here
we then need to combine this purely
geometrical effect with the actual shape
of the wave function which describes an
exponential decay away from the origin
as encoded by this term
the combination of these two effects
leads to this diagram where the volume
effects dominate at low radii and the
exponential decay takes over for larger
radii with a turnover point in the
middle that bleeds to a maximum in the
probability density
to find the location of this maximum all
we need to do is to evaluate the
derivative of p and set it equal to zero
explicitly the derivative takes this
form
and we can evaluate it using the chain
Rule and we get the pre-factor the term
involving the derivative of r squared
and the term involving the derivative of
the exponential
we can take this as a common factor
multiplying by 1 minus r over a0
going back to our derivative at the top
we get this condition for the maximum
we can cancel these terms as they are
positive and we find that the maximum is
for r equal to a0
and this means that the maximum here is
located at a distance a0 from the origin
and what is the meaning of this
the most likely proton electron distance
in the ground state of the hydrogen atom
is a0 which is called the reduced bore
radius
remember that we initially introduced
the reduced bore radius in the video
where we solve the eigenvalue equation
for the hydrogen atom hamiltonian and at
that point it was a purely pragmatic
definition that helped us to simplify
the notation somewhat
we now see that that reduced ball radius
has actually a very important physical
meaning it describes the typical size of
the hydrogen atom which is given by the
most likely distance between the
electron and the proton
okay now that we've seen that the
reduced bore radius has a very important
physical meaning we should evaluate its
actual numerical value
remember the definition of a0 as equal
to this expression in terms of
fundamental physical constants and in
terms of the reduced mass of the proton
electron system
to consider its numerical value we again
need the reduced Mass mu which we said
earlier is equal to
9.104 times 10 to the minus 31 kilograms
we also need the elementary charge which
has this value the permittivity of free
space which is this
and the reduced plan constant which is
this
interesting these numerical values into
the expression at the top we find that
the reduced bore radius is equal to 5.3
times 10 to the minus 11 meters
just like we found in the case of the
ionization energy SI units are not ideal
to describe Atomic premises and we will
instead use the angstrom which is
abbreviated as a capital A with a small
circle at the top
one angstrom is defined as equal to 10
to the minus 10 meters
so with those units the reduced bore
radius is equal to
0.53 angstrom
right so that is the typical size of the
hydrogen atom
while Atomic sizes vary depending on the
element they are often compared to the
size of the hydrogen atom and therefore
described in terms of the bore radius
and for this reason this is a good
number to remember as you continue in
your study of atomic physics chemistry
and Material Science
to finish we're going to explore how the
kinetic and potential energies
separately contribute to the total
energy of the ground state of the
hydrogen atom
to simplify notation we will label the
kinetic energy term with a capital T and
the potential energy term with a capital
Phi
we start with the expectation value of
the hamiltonian in the ground state
which we can explicitly write out like
this
we can use the eigenvalue equation here
to end up with the ground state energy
as the ground state is normalized
from our earlier discussion this is
equal to the negative ionization energy
on top of that as the hamiltonian is the
sum of the kinetic and potential
energies we can also write the
expectation value of the hamiltonian as
equal to the expectation value of the
kinetic energy plus the expectation
value of the potential energy
combining these two results we get to
this relation between the expectation
values of the kinetic and potential
energies with respect to the ground
state wave function
let's next separately consider the
expectation value of the potential
energy in the ground state
spelling out the expression for the
potential energy we can rewrite the
expectation value like this
we can also take this constant factor
out
multiplying the expectation value of 1
over the magnitude of the position
operator
so our next job is to evaluate the
expectation value here which we can
first copy down
using the position representation as
spherical coordinates we can rewrite it
as the angular integrals the radial
integral and then the integrand is 1
over R times the absolute value squared
of the ground state wave function
now recall that the ground stage wave
function has no angular dependence so we
can directly evaluate the angular
integrals which give 4 pi
we can also combine these terms together
to get the integrand of the radial
integral
using the expression we got earlier for
the ground state wave function we end up
with this integrand for the radial
integral
at this point we're going to use this
standard integral which you can look up
in the usual integral tables or just
evaluate it directly
in our case P here is equal to one and
Alpha is equal to 2 over a zero so with
this we can evaluate the expectation
value of 1 over R to get the pre-factors
arising from the angular integrals and
the wave function prefactors
times the result of the standard radial
integral
finally the expression simplifies to
just 1 over a zero
the end result is really very simple the
expectation value of 1 over R in the
ground state is the inverse of the
reduced ball radius
so inserting this back to our expression
for the expectation value of the
potential energy we get this expression
let's make some room
to make progress we need to consider the
ionization energy which remember is
equal to this
we can reorganize the expression for the
ionization energy like this
and we now recognize the term in
Brackets as the inverse of the reduced
Vol radius so that we can write the
ionitation energy in terms of the
reduced or radius like this
if we now compare this expression with
this expression we can conclude that the
ionization energy is equal to minus one
half times the expectation value of the
potential energy
and finally we can write that the
expectation value of the potential
energy is equal to minus twice the
ionization energy
so let's summarize what we have just
found
first we found that the expectation
value of the hamiltonian which can be
written as the sum of the expectation
values of the kinetic energy and the
potential energy is equal to minus the
ionization energy
second we've just found that the
expectation value of the potential
energy can be written as minus two times
the ionization energy
from these results we can now easily
calculate the expectation value of the
kinetic energy
from the top equation the expectation
value of the kinetic energy is equal to
this expression
and inserting the value of the
expectation value of the hamiltonian
here and the value of the expectation
value of the potential energy here we
end up with minus e i minus minus 2
times e i which yields the ionization
energy
so what does this mean
we can write the expectation value of
the potential energy being equal to
minus twice the expectation value of the
kinetic energy
and this result shows that the magnitude
of the potential energy contribution to
the total energy is twice as large as
the contribution from the kinetic energy
for the ground state of the hydrogen
atom
this relation is actually an example of
a more General result known as the
virial theorem and I encourage you to
check out the video that we have Linked
In the description to learn more about
it
but in short the virial theorem
describes a general relation between the
expectation value of the kinetic and
potential energies when the system is in
an energy eigen State these General
relations are useful because they
provide insight into complex systems
without having to do any explicit
calculations like the ones we've done up
here
in the context of the hydrogen atom this
result will be valid not only for the
ground state but also for any excited
state
the analysis of the ground state of the
hydrogen atom has led to some very
important scales that play a key role
across Atomic physics the first one is
the ionization energy which gives the
typical energy scale associated with
atomic systems and the second one is the
bore radius which gives the typical
length scale associated with atomic
systems and that's it for today if you
liked the video please subscribe
foreign